hi my name is Randall Park
and I feel
um
it's neither here nor there okay about
it
[Laughter]
wow uh okay well I think I mean not not
like not in like an offensive I'm not no
no no yeah I just no no I didn't at all
take it that way yeah I just it doesn't
it's like stepping into uh kind of a
lukewarm tub
uh it didn't change your body
temperature at all like an empty tub
are you clothed when you step into this
tub uh yeah okay layers actually yeah
I just I
I mean I'm a I I'm a huge fan I've told
you this I I uh and and of the podcast
I'm a fan of all you guys but I don't
yeah I don't
necessarily want to be a friend no no no
trust me that's like different yeah yeah
uh and I can I just say something you
are demonstrating incredible uh wisdom
you're yeah you you you like the product
uh but you don't want to hang out at the
factory no you're Discerning gentlemen
gentlemen who I will point out this
shows I think great uh great class you
show up with um a brown paper bag I
wasn't sure what was going to happen and
um you reached into it and you pulled
out gifts for uh the the podcast well
yeah I mean yeah I mean this is no one
guess let me tell you something nobody
does that really everybody brings gifts
can you think of anyone Gurley who's
brought a gift the only person I can
think of was Kaley Cuoco sent us gifts
after the fact she sent us little
equestrian mugs and treats really nice
because the question because it went
well and she was like I'm gonna like I'm
doing this without even knowing how this
is going to go so far you're in a deep
hole are you kidding you know okay well
you're on a mountain look at this look
at this okay let's talk about what what
you brought what start with this you
brought
um some purulene chocolate hazelnut
cream filled wafers in a big uh tin so
when we're done eating the Wafers we can
keep uh that's gonna be a swear jar yeah
we should have a swear jar here and then
you brought a bottle of what is the
bottle add to some Irish uh whiskey okay
so because you're you know actually not
don't let the name and face and 100
genetic certitude
fool you
um I'm an Ashkenazi Jew
and very proud of it and uh I haven't
seen you in shul lately oh me yeah oh
quarterly so um or you Randall so no uh
you brought us some bun ratty Irish
whiskey yeah
um and that is a does that say potato
Malta on the bottom no product of
Ireland peated model
I'm looking at it from across the table
and I thought potato mulch you [ __ ]
and there's one for the future uh yes
yeah oh wait a minute and then you
brought us Astro
buffalo chicken wing jerky yeah yeah
look at that and then the the well
that's interesting look at I like the
logo is uh it has a cow in a in a space
a cow in a space suit floating in orbit
um yeah I went to the store right down
the street but the wine and uh cheese
store and
grab the first things I saw okay okay
well I do think this should be a
precedent now on the podcast because I
think people should bring gifts
um and over time
not that these are these are fine gifts
what what no no don't get an attitude
but over time the gifts will you know
improve I think uh maybe the amount
spent
um there'll be some fine watches maybe
uh if I come back yeah
if I come back oh you are coming back
you know I want to first uh uh
compliment you on and thank you when I
was wrapping up my late night show and
we were doing some of our last
you know a couple of weeks of months of
episodes yeah you showed up and uh you
brought
you to this hilarious thing on our show
it's the hardest I've laughed on on
camera in a long time you very seriously
sold at what a good artist you are and
how much you've been working and
um you I swear to God I knew nothing
about this sometimes people were very
cynical about talk shows and they think
well the host knows everything that's
going to happen yeah we know some things
but I don't I like to not know some
things and you did not tell me this so
you were talking for a while about how
good you were and you were very
convincing very good and then you
totally had me Hook Line and Sinker and
I was so excited and then you you talked
very seriously about covid and you've
been working on it and you thought you
got really good and your style and
you're getting a lot of compliments and
then you showed me uh this this you put
so much pressure on it and then you
showed me this uh a portrait you had
done of me I'm blown away I would love
to see this and it's pretty amazing
it looks like a photograph yeah right
it's like funny how like you know it's
like riding a bike it just you just pick
up where you left off
and it was terrible in the funniest way
it was so it was it was so and that's
very hard to achieve it got a huge
reaction from the crowd
um I couldn't stop laughing we kept
showing it people loved it I took it
home my wife came home she couldn't stop
laughing because you had it in a little
frame you framed it yeah and um it is
that my kids came home they couldn't
stop laughing guess what it is still in
our kitchen oh my gosh I love that look
at it every day every day I'm like I'm
busy I've got stuff to do and sometimes
I'm in a bad mood and then I see this
portrait that uh an original by Rainbow
Park that's right me oh I love that it's
still in your home it's hilariously do
you have it yes
sincerely my Approach was to like draw
you good like to try to draw you good oh
well then and then something would I
knew something would be off because uh
that I'm not no type and then just just
to accentuate the thing that's oh that's
not a little off but that's what's thing
it's it is a thing of profound Beauty
and Gorly am I right it is it's very
hard it's very hard to be slight I mean
this is like the best uh version of The
Uncanny Valley you know like you've
somehow made that art as opposed to like
the lack of Art and I'm always I swear
to God I'm always going to have this I
love it and visible because it's an
uncanny Mountain I think that makes
sense yeah it's it's uh it is truly uh
well that's an honor a gift that keeps
on giving I love that I love that